how's it going everyone it's Warren and
we have some more Avengers endgame leaks
and again these leaks point to the
quantum realm and time travel /
alternate realities so we've had many
leaks about this same thing before it
started with the back of a box for a toy
that had Thor and Rocket in some sort of
white suits on the back of it and then
we got some leaked photos of a good
majority of the Avengers wearing these
white suits in some concept art /
prototype art and then there were some
leaks of toys that came out that showed
the Avengers wearing these white suits
and now it seems like we have some
official Avengers endgame merchandise
that's come out in the UK of these
quantum realm suits as you can see here
there is a hat and a jacket that we've
never seen before and they have the same
white red and black design that we saw
in these previous leaks now a lot of
people think that these new white suits
that the Avengers are going to wear are
for going inside of the quantum realm
and I think so as well
especially after the brand-new Super
Bowl TV spot for Avengers in game that
we just saw a few days ago it's clear
that ant-man arrives pretty early in the
movie which was to be expected I didn't
think he was going to spend a good
majority of the movie inside of the
quantum realm so it's clear that he
shows up pretty early on in the movie
and he obviously is going to explain the
quantum realm to the remaining Avengers
and from there some of the scientists on
the team are going to figure out a way
to get back inside the quantum realm and
possibly use it for time travel or to go
into different realities and Hank Pym
made it very clear in the first ant-man
movie that they're going to need a
special sort of suit to go inside of the
quantum realm and that is what I believe
we're seeing here with all of these new
leaks for these white suits and this is
just even more evidence for all of these
other leaks that have come out some
people have been saying that they're
fake but now there is quite a bit of
evidence pointing towards the fact that
they are in fact real and will most
likely see them in avengers endgame so
let me know your thoughts on this new
merch that's come out in the comments
down below do you like how they look and
do you think they are for traveling
inside of the quantum realm let me know
and don't forget about my giveaway
giving away five imax tickets so you and
some friends can go see Avengers and
in IMAX all you have to do to enter the
giveaway is subscribe to my channel like
the video and comment down below with
your thoughts and your favorite
character that could be a superhero or
villain as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you
[Music]